it all started on Twitter one tweet
after another and then you know boom we
end up in the arena previously in the
Rainbow six siege arena it all started
with some friendly Twitter banter
between two 49er wide receivers marquise
Goodwin and Pierre Garcon
what followed is a generous invitation
from GameSpot to settle the score in
Rainbow six siege with the seams decided
Marquis and Pierre received a crash
course in Rainbow six siege tactics and
strategy
[Music]
[Applause]
Rainbow six free weekend lands on August
16th and to celebrate Marquis and Pierre
will compete to determine who gets to
claim ultimate bragging rights in the
siege arena we are in the Rainbow six
siege arena and it is on we've got team
garçon versus team Goodwyn for game time
baby it's game time and I'm going up
there so bomb is the premier competitive
mode for Rainbow six basically the way
it works is that there are two bombs on
the map if you're the defenders you got
to keep those bombs alive if you're the
attackers you got to plan a little
gadget it's called the defuser and then
it stops the bombs from going on oh they
shot me oh I got shot my dude is hella
slow yep I told you the other wind
conditions are if an entire side is
eliminated all the defenders die or if
all the attackers die then they win
there you go I got supposed go ahead and
expand and push dude so you're like
intelligence thank hanger right
hanger right there should be some stairs
my dad Mark he's about to get
interrogated and as you can see
everybody's positions team Garcon gets
round wanted me out - Mia - Mia ah come
on hey y'all gotta hold it down y'all
gotta hold it down
y'all gotta hold it down for me you got
it you gotta just hey sometime is like
this in the game right that's right down
to five seconds
wow he's having a hard time shooting
that drone marques is just hauling it
right now
down the field oh he scared me my gosh i
holding angles which is what tux bird is
doing right now and he sees Nick and
that'll be the first kill it's good on
defense the whole day it's a nun attack
you can hold angles too he'll get
another on cartoons for it located may
CJ gets a pill into Nasir and you can
see Marquis is down Oh get finished on
Oxford so he's gonna go to plant the
defuser here nice let's go let's go
he'll finish the kill may CJ eliminated
by rush
or can you can hear them howl in the
background
ah alright I'm coming in looking for you
keys I fellas I got to step it up I got
to step it up doing the classic armor by
the pool table
ok I'm gonna bust this breaching shard
we're gonna run in all right you ready
all right three two one
go go go go go go
Nik is gonna get kill number one takes
out the rook of Sammy Jo
baby let's go one touch before it gets
taken out and that makes ajit doing
greenies you Nasir will have to fetch
that defuser in the next 40 seconds in
order to have something happen for his
team
this is math is a big maze still nails
still no defuser though for the black
dirt he'll have to go get it he's
running out of time five seconds that
Nassar gonna have a chance that's if you
cannot play up there and team Garcon
I'll let you guys down sorry it's all
good good Pierre ain't killed nobody no
I'm coming for you here seems pretty
comfortable in castle house he's used in
every single round oh I see somebody I
see Pierre oh you see me come get me
[Laughter]
yeah you can run but you can't hide
sit down here I told you - mo I told you
- mo cartoon sees one he'll finish off
the look Sammy Jo gunne alright alright
touch bird with a pistol kill takes out
cartoons Marquesas gal until oh oh okay
I'm back I'm back oh I got killed but
there's touch bird taking out Marquis ah
he'll let's go
him give it matter it's possible it's
possible
come on where's it in touch bird has
every kill so far he'll lead to get it
was the quarry seize the fuse
like some up and knocks him down what a
round detox bird we got to get this one
fellas when I go home and I cannot let
Pierre go to the locker room and tell
them heat off me you got to kill us
that's the name of the game let's go
come on team do not let them in cartoons
cease the entry of may CJ they'll
exchanged fire and cartoons now having
to deal with the Montaigne fully
extended duxford pushing in and we see a
possible kill here Phil is down cartoons
trying to deal with the Montaigne but no
may see changes all good it's all good
yo-yo there they're coming in where he
died they're coming everybody in your
spot oh I felt that the wall gets blown
right next to him I don't think he knows
it but there's a giant a gaping hole
tech behind o zy b IG YB hey how do you
marquees how do you I see right here I
see ya hey do the tilt out of you I got
you boy I got you boy he's coming
we got you 20 seconds baby hold it down
20 seconds I got you
oh maybe he's down here that's too
narrow he'll get it off just in the nick
of time I can play just about 10 seconds
let's destroy it I'm gonna juice here
I'll pick you up I'll pick you up all
we're gonna do we said to defuse that we
gotta destroy the defuser where is it
where is it where is it okay right here
right here hold that bond it hold up on
it you got it you got it hold that
bought it you got it I'll do it if you
don't want to just gonna destroy this
lunchbox to win the round
don't worry about we got it that's it we
got it let's talk about baby that's what
a team work days real word and we ain't
come back we on the comeback we got a
comeback on our hand
[Music]
once again here we go cartoons going for
a impact grenade that's a rotate hole
and help open that sight wall up that's
behind us so you can hear if you could
hear their comms they're calling them
push is coming open it up baby open it
all up ears down Sam's down there all by
the pool table
let's go numbers no there are about a
pool table hey we got him in okay I hear
somebody I hope it was
come on Marky oh yeah I got you I got
you I got you
you're coming in coming in coming in
I've been spotted through that extended
wall basically eliminating Nick is going
to draw this a little bit closer
together [ __ ] down
subi do we got come on boys Oxford will
fully deploy his shield and push in he's
gonna see good one can go advantage
we merely put that perfect
[Music]
those w's let's go let's go around the
corner me I love my bay you can salsa
dance over there all you want if that
would say Real Talk that's fun we need
that that's what hey that's what a dub
was like knee pad I'm going to get to
victory
I'm kidding we're going to get the
victory I'll put it all on my back put
it all on my back and we'll go together
so here we go still match point Ken team
Goodwyn win a third round in a row
controller is shaken
it's me coming to get you that's what a
second I mean this working so I don't
know
exothermic charge will go off rushing
badger gonna get that heck out of it the
cartoons eliminated nation Ginny's out
he's out of the action Nick in the
position where Marquis was before
waiting to see where the pushin is gonna
happen from Pierre alongside Montague
get them get them get them it's 3 2 1
it's 3 2 1 we need this we need this
Teague that's going teamwork make the
dream op here you know Marquis has been
sitting in the vault every single round
you want if we can push that and go for
him
we're just follow me and we're gonna go
for more it alright alright I like that
idea
oh I got you
what Marquis is down already
I was coming to get him
here we'll wander through the doorway
where the EVD had gone off before
duxford of tanked most of that damage
and he's gonna get pressed up can't we
see a kill I got the air coming to kill
I got to got to take that's all I care
about
take the air out I'm just gonna start
planning this yeah hey CJ right now
holding the angle on the window the
rotate as the diffuser getting planted
this is going to be a major obstacle
[Music]
one from Nick and Russian Bajor
as it's a 3 V 3 this is winnable for the
defense and if I'm team gar saw I'm
gonna be holding on for dear life
philanthropy very low on health the rest
of his team both Sammy and Mei CJ always
right next to the doorway right next to
the doorway you got it you gotta go for
the defuser go oh they are me Nick we'll
have to hurry but he's almost out of
time and it will strike looks like it's
the team gar saw taking the
today was a very unfortunate day for my
opponent that called me out yeah you
know I gave him what he wanted and it
was a complete defeat I had a blast most
definitely do us again same people
everyone over here was having a blast
and it was it was a good time here
didn't like one kid no I actually had
more than well in everyone one kill and
two in training he got killed every time
before I their strategic during the
match I wasn't mean that was our
strategy yeah my teammates back
sacrificial lamb in until he was a
sacrificial man they show me coming in
to save my team a to get the kill my MVP
would be yeah he got a kill with a
sledge shotgun it was on me actually I
guess I don't have a choice but to say
he's my MVP because it's kind of he made
it so it hurts because I see him every
single day all day and he will not let
me live this down
look at look at him look at this trophy
like you thought this helped me wait
enough like they go he's gonna need a
big element for this season
[Music]
while this competition is over yours is
just beginning
rainbow succeed is free-to-play from
August 16th to the 19th jump in this
weekend to settle your own scores good
night